lose the side are gonna be going up
against each other it's gonna be lily
versus kazuya one of these guys has to
go home
and it's either gonna be fgl or the dark
prince lily versus kazuya first to
action
all right violet systems or this is all
going to go down uh one of the most
technical kazuya players uh that i've
seen
uh not just in you know in these combo
videos but even in in tournament play
going against this this out of nowhere
this lily beast
yeah
fairly good fairly good
yeah fairly good lily
all right still first interaction though
oh my god are you serious
the electric that was tight
he he do glided underneath the electric
and hot kicks are you serious
and the punish here
oh you gotta believe
nice four four three able to land here
pushing towards the other side steel
pedal
just the tip
oh no see that's the thing you gotta you
got like i said live and dive by the
sword that while standing too ended up
costing him the round round two
yeah fight and you know it's one of
those things you're gonna realize very
early on is that fgl most of time is
gonna punish you very hard for your for
your mistakes
nice dash electric
oh nice good stuff try to hop over but
no tech roll low parry
great recognition into the stone head
and taking the round here dark prince on
the scoreboard tied up
again reminder to everyone that's
watching this is a first to two first to
two yeah
this could be complicated
punish
yeah i like the patience here from fgl
taking the opportunities back he does
have rage as well darth vader is gonna
have to be careful on how he's gonna
space out the offense as he goes in yeah
because that rage rock could kill punish
that no punishment oh interesting he
didn't get the punish oh the matterhorn
into the launch
and dark prince was ready for it man
that padding wasn't not gonna work on me
nice up three neutral
that electric pressure is so sick
oh he's fighting back starting to pull
out folks big counter oh no
oh this is unfortunate
that would have been massive damage
there but he dropped it once again gets
caught jabbing
and dark prince doing a really good job
to deduct him and launch spot nice look
at the hell sweet
yeah great block he's gonna push towards
the wall he's not gonna get the wall but
what's he gonna do here low into the low
double low all right fine around first
game
punish good stuff there from dog prince
again
right underneath it with the duck whilst
i don't want to
big lead here for dark prince looking to
take it but he's at the wall he's gonna
have to be careful nice punish there fgl
taking the throw
oh my god
don't get don't put him into rage if
you're gonna hit him you better kill him
you do not oh
you do not want to deal with the blue
thunder
yeah he did a great job of sealing away
the move options using quick moves like
the down forward four for that
interruption at the end and really just
controlling the tone of the match you
know the few times that we did see the
round wins and and things kind of turn
around there uh for fgl it's because the
wrists that we're taking whether it was
the hell suite the wall setting two and
of course he got punished for it but the
dark pits ended up kind of like dialing
things a little bit back and and waiting
for these opportunities and making sure
he was able to capitalize so many with
electric punishes there and i like i
like seeing it it was good stuff there
very methodical first match and i think
uh it's kind of putting uh fdl on notice
really he has to kind of make an
adjustment here he went for that
matterhorn can he try to catch him with
a few things here and there but you know
timing is everything timing is
everything and kazuya was on top of the
game
and having that electric i think it
really slows down the game too because
you know you have to make sure that you
don't overextend it can catch you very
easily especially when you've got dark
prince going for the dash electric the
wavy wave electrics which will track you
when you're trying to sidewalk um there
was a situation there where fgl could
have won dalford won um
downfall 142
uh
i believe it is at least minus 12. i i'm
not sure someone could correct me but if
it is then
uh you could get a knockdown
yeah would have got the 4-2-3 into the
wall splat instead of just the jabs and
that would have been the round so fgr
needs to you know level up his a
punishment game like he has been doing
all day today i know you know
tournaments can often times be a battle
of endurance and he needs to have that
endurance if you want if he wants to get
into this top three here we go we're on
devil's pit now so we have the walls of
play and we have the infinite in play
too all in one here we go 1-0 to dark
prince right now can fgl bring it back
i mean i feel like story wise to do is
undefeated at this stage
gotta be careful you gotta know what
you're getting into anyways we have the
wall here let's see if gl's able to
fight back nice punish that's the
punishment we need to see
here we go
great stuff here again brandishing that
electric trying to keep him
open
goes through the wall standing three
uh-huh ready locked and loaded while
standing one two he's gonna be able to
push towards the wall here
what's the mix oh my goodness low jab
had to stop the pressure somehow
what about you that's what we wanted to
see
if he had done that the last match he
would have won the match but here we go
better late than never
this is how it starts
about even on life but again ready
induction while standing one two looking
to close it out oh my god oh my god what
optimal spacing for that combo
dark prince crazy taking that round
no darkness
but that power crush helped that power
push is huge it's a huge risk because
let's say it does get blocked he gets
launched for it but either way
here we go this is gonna hurt
two rounds to one sgl looking to sign
things up again this is a race to two
games dark prince has a chance to
eliminate fgl from the tournament but
he's gonna oh my god the hell sweets are
coming out and this is how it starts
look at the wave
the wavy wavers have a gun the wiggle
wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle
oh the wiggle dance he's caught in there
i'm gonna go to a final round dogfish
has a big life
my
league
all right here we go
probably the most important round for
both of these players
oh it beat the electric
yeah polish
nice nice good punish there oh and he
gets that that's unfortunate for dark
prince he's gonna put him in rage yes he
does but don't get hit by the blue stuff
do not get in by
his choice of offense at the very end
was so good
went for this the knee and of course
just following up with the low the
timing of it all was just perfect and he
was able to clutch it out that was great
stuff final match coming up
yeah an over extension there from dark
prince when he was on the floor he went
for a get up kick in the submissive heel
managed to get catch the counter hit and
that's big damage man on that downforce
through used to miss the field when you
get it on counter here and allowed him a
way back in it was a risk that he didn't
need to take you know in those
situations i mean obviously hindsight is
20 20 but trying to get up in the safest
way possible you know lily doesn't have
the most scary lows just back roll get
returned back to neutral and you had the
live lead uh went for a get up kick
there which was a bit of a risky thing
to do but we're going to a final match
now mark and uh i wonder what um
dark prince is thinking is he gonna be
composed and stick with the kazuya or is
he gonna panic and go to another
character
it's been rare that we've seen dark
chris push to this kind of situation
right and the last time that we saw it
he switched to devil gin
i wouldn't be surprised if you switched
again devil gin great character has a
ton of tools tools that may be useful in
this particular match up but we'll see
we'll see how it plays out for him
absolutely where are we gonna go what is
he gonna do
yeah he's sticking with his pride and
glory
the dark prince with kazuya going into
twilight conflict he goes for the stage
pick
and it's all come down to this the final
match winner of this will go up against
nasir balal in our losers final where it
would be a race to three
yep absolutely and having that balcony
in play as you can see on screen right
now is going to be quite instrumental
potentially for dark prince if you can
manage to get fgl to the wall and
utilize it hell sweep ladies and gents
get it it's final match it all comes
down to this
let's get it
just like you said yeah this is
important
whoever wins this match wins it all nice
he got the back too did not have the car
finish it there but look at that
matterhorn cannon the follow up here
he's gonna get the wall as well
what's the mix oh my god that's the mix
of evil sometimes all it takes is the
confidence in doing the lows
to
that that momentum against your opponent
and right now fgl
with the lead here in the in the match
and doc prince decided to look at
everything right now oh he tried to get
him down
if it hits in that particular angle that
he was going for it guarantees an
electric launch
oh okay
all right all right counter hitting
there's the fourth round while ending
one plus two i like it he gets the
follow-up as well
let's see what he does
i mean for the most part fgl has
sound defense and at least in fighting
the options that kazuya has
yeah
oh my god he's putting him in the test
you try to go for the try to get him off
the wall there side step two four it
could be it yes fgl now on set point to
eliminate dark pinch from the tournament
are we gonna get a fight to find around
though
my
dark prince he's not out yet but fgl is
looking really strong momentum wise
he does have a live lead as well dark
prince is gonna have to pick shots here
he's gonna have to be very very careful
oh he caught him with the ball the big
left leg falling down on his forehead
no it missed he wasn't he wasn't he
wasn't high enough
what yeah for a grab
nice use this
up
dangerous
oh
it's gonna go right down to the wire 60
seconds left rage drive spent ftl with
rage available as well he uses it
resources
the dark prince played out of his mind
throughout the entire day from
everything that we've seen from him but
fairly good lily fgl
came out on top once again now
guaranteeing himself a top three finish
in the tournament great stuff so far
absolutely man yeah again like i wanna i
wanna
join you in congratulating uh dark
prince on a very good tour